- I woke up 15 minutes ago.
I'm hung over.
Let's get my ears pierced.
- I kinda feel like there's two
kinds of people in the world
people who look good with earrings and me.
- I think rappers wear
earrings to bling, to flash,
to be like, "Yo, look, look at my status,
look at how much money I got."
- I think it can look
really good on some people,
and then other people just
look like douche bags,
so I don't know how it's
gonna turn out for me.
- I don't know.
My sister's ears are pierced.
My mom's ears are pierced.
Why not?
- I'm super nervous about getting
I hate needles, like
anything with a needle,
I just wanna faint.
- I got a tattoo, but I'm more nervous
about this ear getting pierced.
- You guys better start soon or
I'm gonna run outta this room.
- I am the piercer and owner
of Body Electric Tattoo.
- How big are the holes normally?
- Feels like I'm in the
waiting room to Hell.
- [Brian] All right, give
me a big, deep breath
all the way in,
all the way out.
That's it.
Nothing to it.
How was it?
- Yeah, that was nothing.
I knew it.
- This ain't gone be nuthin.
You see this?
I'm ?? all the time
- Give me a big, deep breath
all the way in,
all the way out.
Done.
- That happened.
That just happened.
- [Brian] How you feel, dude?
- I feel great.
- [Brian] Ready if you are.
- I guess I'm ready as I'm gonna be,
but I'm not, but I am, but I ha ha
- [Brian] Give me a big, deep breath
all the way in,
all the way out.
Done.
- Aah, like Kelly Clarkson,
that...
stung a little bit
- [Brian] Give me a big, deep breath
all the way in,
all the way out.
Done.
Good job.
- Wait, we did it?
- Oh (beep).
Yeah, I like these a lot actually.
- Looks good.
- [Brian] You like it?
- Yeah, good placement.
- [Brian] Cool
- All I need is like a rain
machine and a wind machine
and a shirt metal things, and
I'll be like an R&B singer.
- I feel like a whole different person.
Feel like I'm more bad ass now.
- It was fine. It was 2 seconds.
It was just a little bit of pressure.
- Maybe I'll hate 'em in a
week, and I can throw them off
and be like, (beep) this,
but at least I tried it.
Yolo.
- I got the metal one hoping that
it's a chick magnet literally.